[Music]
promise me this I've got now 15 years of
being right about this [ __ ] in 18 months
and 36 months in 48 months when I'm like
lollipop is the [ __ ] everybody get on
lollipop make your [ __ ] augmented
reality [ __ ] icon go I'm telling you
lollipop this is just like tick tock
it's just like Twitter that time that
next time Dave I need you to [ __ ] go
immediately blinding being like I [ __ ]
with Gary Vee [ __ ] it I'm not making the
same mistake because if you go on to cut
today versus when I [ __ ] told
everybody to go on it you left [ __ ]
millions of views on the table you can't
get big like that no more because
everyone's on the top you got your
perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning world really excited April
2nd
Thursday the background that I am most
accustomed to big shout out to Dustin
for getting me this image I'm feeling
now comfortable and cozy and normal it
is tea with Gary be a little bit of sad
news only gonna be able to do an hour
this morning so we'll get through as
much as we can
sorry it's start with a disappointment
but a little bit of excitement was just
look at my calendar and I'm like okay
the only we're only doing an hour of tea
with Gary B should we do an hour later
this afternoon with wine with Gary
Vaynerchuk so we're gonna figure that
out later today look for those updates
on social media if we decide to go that
route big shout-out to Reddit and
Instagram and Twitter which I know
streaming live and obviously the
mainframe on LinkedIn and Facebook good
morning good morning good morning Dustin
I'm ready to go into the first call good
morning what's your name awesome see how
are things how do you do [ __ ] my my
favorite way to deal with [ __ ] is
with compassion and I mean this I
believe that [ __ ] are broken inside
and they're projecting their pain and
and I get a ton of it I get a ton of
negative feedback because I'm just out
there so much for all the positive
feedback I get I I just I deal with some
you know sympathy compassion and empathy
I just genuinely know I know that people
project in the outside what's happening
on the inside and so I deal with
[ __ ] very easily
I feel bad for them honestly and and and
I think not being able to do that is a
little bit more of an indication of
one's own security and self esteem so
it's a to play tack right it's it's very
easy once you actually you know a lot of
people have never heard what I'm saying
which is like there
her inside and then and then if it still
bothers you you have to ask yourself why
are you believing somebody that you
don't even know sure so do you believe
in just blocking and moving on or do
sometimes like feel compelled to
actually comment or give in to their
pettiness
I've never blocked anybody number number
two I ignore 99% uh-huh and I engaged 1%
with sweetness and kindness one of the
more interesting things that happens in
my community on Twitter or Instagram
that I see often is I'll come and be the
bigger person and say you know and say
Rick pants 57 I'm sorry you feel bad
but I'm not a sneaker salesmen I'm not
selling anything what do you think I'm
selling here I'm putting out love I have
a business I'm not trying to sell you I
don't know where you're coming up with
that and I wish nothing but health when
I do that you know 50% times somebody
that person will come back and say I'm
sorry I'm just having a bad day 50% of
times they'll double down but then I'm
Alice I've said what I've had to say
that's how and that's how I've navigated
the last 12 years once you have that
also be beneficial in real life too but
obviously there's a few of us like
myself included that issue like writing
the tongue and knowing when not to say
anything that's right there's a lot of
people who are you know I'm a big
believer of being the bigger person in
every situation there's you know there's
also the saying and I for nine right and
a lot of people when they get hurt they
want to they want to hurt back or not
bite their tongue but spit a little bit
um I'm empathetic to that and that and
that is okay but it is absolutely an
indication of one's own insecurities it
absolutely is and so I think it's super
important to do two things in parallel
one lean in with more compassion and
love instead of punch back and really
understand that that person like see
like do you understand how much of a
sucky life it is for somebody to take
time go on somebody else's profile and
say you're stupid you're ugly like
they're in a bad
in place and then number two really
think about you know why is that trigger
it's actually triggering you because
there is a little bit of like self-doubt
I would attack I would work on that on
oneself and say I am beautiful I am
smart I am capable and most importantly
everybody has strengths and weaknesses I
think humility in oneself helps with
that you know I actually think I suck at
so many things and I know that I'm wrong
at times that actually helps me deal
with that as well great question Dustin
that one's gonna work on Instagram as a
choppa how do you deal with [ __ ]
that I could see a million views on that
on Instagram right now yeah split screen
that team feel good foodie is next I'm
excited about that
hello hello hi Gary how's it going
thanks for having me on of course what's
your name Yuna we do a feel-good foodie
it's really good to see you feel good
foodie yes
so um should I jump in the question you
sure great so here's here's what's going
on so we're all in an unprecedented time
right now and I'm actually very lucky
though to be working in the food
industry and so as a food blogger a lot
of people are turning to food for
comfort or you know all the reasons so
for me I've had record number of
pageviews record number of profile
visits record number of people like
remaking my recipes yet my struggle
right now is how do I get brands to
actually want to do sponsored work
because all of a sudden March 10th
March 11 like just came screeching to a
halt like nobody wants to do that
anymore you don't food companies are
tightening up you know you know
yesterday one of our clients emailed us
and said we're not paying you this is
seven figures and you're getting fired
and we might be going bankrupt you don't
get that you don't get to effect the
other side what you do right now is a
hopefully you've either saved or your
humble enough to go backwards this is
for everybody be
you go ham I'm producing as much content
doing as many lives going across every
platform even trying to even waiting to
do tick-tock you've been waiting to do
Twitter you do all that now you build up
so in 180 days when shits truly back to
normal you're [ __ ] getting that this
is chess right now not checkers it's not
direct it's macro so go ham like all in
like so many people are dwelling I've
heard from a thousand of you already
yeah like Gary I'm crushing but all my
money's gone because the brands aren't
sponsoring I'm like uh-huh I'm like
remember when I told you if there was a
recession like influencers wouldn't be
as fun anymore yes good news this a fake
recession aka it doesn't have the
underlining principles to be something
super long it's likely [ __ ] will get
back to normal somewhere here later I
mean the biggest the biggest elephant in
the room is if this reopened winter like
some experts are saying then you're
starting to get into some [ __ ] but but
if not then you know we're gonna be back
to normal somewhere in the next 90 120
160 180 days I think you need to build
build build big bill and then take the
opportunities when they come okay so it
doesn't matter how many eyeballs are on
that count right now how many eyeballs
are you know online making the food it
doesn't you can't really pitch that
because the brands just have this idea
right now that it's not a good time to
spend money regardless of what's
happened and everybody like you is also
up right it's you know it's all about
supplying to be I got it yes you and
everybody else right right any sense
yeah that makes me right now build depth
of community getting in people's souls
right and so that they stay with you
after the fact okay that's a really good
advice actually excellent thank you take
care
King what's good what's poppin Gary yeah
all right so my question is basically
how do you feel not feel like a failure
like um 20 and I have done a lot with my
life and I everybody tells me I'm
successful but I always feel like a
failure still why I don't know honestly
like [ __ ] three years ago honest as
[ __ ]
so this reason is like because when I
was younger my family always I kind of
told me like I would not be like [ __ ] or
I'm not gonna be successful so it's like
I kind of worked my ass off to get to
where I am now and I still don't see the
success that I feel that validates me
you know and it's like I always didn't
tell myself like no like you've got to
really stop this [ __ ] because like you
are successful and you're getting more
success but you're like reminds me of
tricks on you okay first success has to
be redefined in our culture bro like
success needs to be happiness not how
many you know zeros are in the bank
account or how many followers one has so
a on some real [ __ ] being as young a man
as you are knowing that you're gonna
live four or five more lives you need to
seriously in its own self really think
especially when you're coming from
hip-hop culture looking at your backdrop
so much of success isn't what you got
what you're wearing who you with how
much you drop how much you spent like
please please my man let's use the
serendipity of this moment together to a
start right now just like you know just
like your family pounded from the get
which is hard to get out
you know stablish them in the beginning
it's hard to get out but a write from
this moment please use this and watch
this video over again success needs to
be are you happy yeah are you happy ,
you need to really go into this like
place a quiet place like this this cave
inside your own head where you need to
be like on some real [ __ ] you'll [ __ ] my
grandma [ __ ] mom [ __ ] dad [ __ ] my
grandfather [ __ ] my uncle but like you
need to go into this place because every
piece of value that they have over you
is gonna always then go back to that
place where you don't think you're [ __ ]
yeah Anse ablution now that doesn't mean
you have to never talk to them again and
[ __ ] them yeah yeah
you just can't value their opinion so
you need to [ __ ] on their opinion yes
you need and by the way for you and
everybody else people have to look at
where that opinion comes from I don't I
have a friend who like really had issues
with his bond growing up and his mom was
a wreck a wreck and finally I looked at
him like this is when I was like 16 I
was like bro
your mom's a [ __ ] loser why are you
listening to her yeah you know just you
know like you know you don't get to
choose who your family is but like you
know which then leads to you don't get
to choose who's [ __ ] putting [ __ ]
into your dome but the reality is suck
like you to your point if you've already
quote-unquote won more than they said
then now the whole rest of this game the
next hundred years is gravy yeah bro you
need to put positivity in your ears you
know all those posters behind you right
yes
why are they icons why are they sitting
on your [ __ ] wall because they put
out stories and people put that [ __ ] in
their ears and that took him to a
different place it they resonated with
it
it was positivity right and so you know
sometimes it seemed rugged but it was
optimism I can get out right and so what
you need to do now is at all classes for
you and everybody else spend a hundred
percent of your time putting practical
positivity not some [ __ ] like if you
dream it without some hippy [ __ ] yeah
practical positivity into your [ __ ]
ear and limit limit that poison are you
able to do that yeah I actually got
better at it cuz like last year in 29
teams I'm really bad I was very
depressed with 20/20 I was depressed
because I let me tell me the truth I let
a lot of things get to me I let myself
be like paralyzed you know like by like
people's actions towards me like thank
you
tell me the truth fake friends like
management my people not like not
getting my full money stealing money
like all that stuff I'd really affected
me and then if I like took a break from
social media like took a break back but
now I 2025 post every day on YouTube I
started to talking about almost two mil
that's about getting deals every day
Brando's deals every day I'm doing great
on everything that I wanted to do and
I'm doing
cut poison out of your life yeah you
know the you ever see Bronx I think it's
Bronx Tale where like the kid like sees
a kid that he went 20 bucks to and he
still owes him 20 bucks I think it
starts like chasin and the gangster
grabs him and says yo you got off cheap
any manager any friend or girl that just
hung out with you because you had some
money but like all that thing you could
cut you're in control
you cut them out I'm never mad when
people try to floss off me or gloss off
me you know why I'm in control
hey at this point and even from the get
I'm hard to trick but be if somebody got
me because I didn't give a [ __ ] if they
trick me I can cut them on the [ __ ]
energy yeah bro this is a positive
versus negative
yes verse no yeah good versus bad
[ __ ] world
[ __ ] lean into good and [ __ ] cut
that out 24/7 365 period and go back to
your life in your mind the last seven or
eight years and think about what was
bringing you good vibes and like I keep
telling so many people I'm like find
that kid in high school that you now
think as a nerd because they're not as
cool but they were your [ __ ] homie
and junior high but you think you're a
little something you're trying to be
popular you can't be friends with them
and [ __ ] go back to that person and
be friends again because that's positive
energy instead of the [ __ ] negative
energy if somebody you're looking up to
okay
babe what's good hey how you doing I'm
really well how are you were you from I
live in South Carolina antastic I like
the office setup at first I was like he
went to the office today I know I'm so
happy what's good less T so I'm uh so I
do a lot of things how should I explain
it I uh
I kind of want to work in or work and
create something that focuses on a bunch
of things that I like and then just kind
of create one singular sort of brand
around it
i watch a lot of anime which is not the
question I love you
all I make music lotsa rap music and I
love fashion sneakers blah blah Street
where all that stuff so I'm trying to be
rackin contemporary culturally relevant
kid yeah so exactly so so I'm trying to
think of ways to build something around
that create something really strong for
me personally in which I can do all of
those things i DJ I make music I make
beats I record music I you know make
clothes that brand blah blah blah blah
blah you're Renaissance man yeah yeah
and that's that's I feel like that super
normal right now it is cuz the internet
lets you do that yeah and a lot of
people try to get you to focus on one
thing but if I can wrong people are yeah
people are trying to get you focus on
one thing you're the people that focus
on one thing in a boring as [ __ ] so I
guess with all of that I'm trying to
figure out good ways to grow in all the
spaces more than I have been it's not
going poorly it's not going amazingly so
it's kind of those things where if
you're trying to ready let me break you
down you could actually get more
followers and get more paper if you just
go potentially if you go all-in on
whichever one of those six things you're
best at you could you also wouldn't be
[ __ ] you and you wouldn't be happy
yes so my big thing too the [ __ ]
world is would you rather be happy and
have a little less following and a
little less money or would you rather be
sadder and have more following a blue
check and a couple more dollars it's a
real simple question now my favorite
part what I actually know my soul is if
you actually stay the course and are
just yourself the whole way you're
always one piece of content either an
anime either in a beat either in a rhyme
either the thing you're always one
moment away from things popping off and
then you can say wait a minute this just
went viral this just went fire Drake
just like this what do I do
then you can decide if you want to go
in on that thing at that moment but it
was that happiness and I continuous
making that allowed you to get to that
serendipity so I don't think it's an
either/or I actually think you will be
bigger make more money if you stay the
course of being Renaissance man it just
takes time bro
I got [ __ ] me videos for six seven
years before anybody gave a [ __ ] oh yeah
I know that's the thing and I've already
I've accepted doing everything I've been
through meeting years of my friends
telling me you should just be a
photographer you should just make music
you should just you know do whatever and
so I'm past that I'm at that point but
it really just sounds like you're saying
just keep grinding it out and you'll in
the end yes because you'll be happy some
people are not talented and they
eventually never really make it but
there is one other overlay how long have
you been following me uh years years
actually okay cuz one of those watched a
levy and then I stopped I'm not too much
a fan of weak levy so I like got into
and I was like oh this isn't for me and
I've sort of moved on but it's probably
been five years in total
so now a really important question when
I started going ham a year-plus ago on
tick tock how quickly did you go on
or did you I just started that I've been
trying let's stop right on right there
that yeah I'm gonna give you something
real powers of your bro that yes keep
grinding but please understand that when
there's a new platform and there's a
land grab of attention next time go hard
I must make this tape promise me this
I've got now 15 years of being right
about this [ __ ] in 18 months and 36
months in 48 months when I'm like
lollipop is the [ __ ] everybody get on
lollipop make your [ __ ] augmented
reality [ __ ] icon so I'm telling you
this is just like tick tock is just like
Twitter that time that next time Dave I
need you to [ __ ] go immediately
blinding being like [ __ ] with Gary Vee
[ __ ] it I'm not making the same mistake
because if you go on to cut today versus
when I [ __ ] told everybody to go on
it you left [ __ ]
millions of views on the table you can't
get big like that no more because
everyone's haven't talked yep
that's a thing I think I was concerned
about you know I think yesterday you
talked about how every social network
starts is one thing and then everything
yeah exactly so I immediately am like
I'm not dancing I'm not making memes I'm
not doing blah blah blah things that
don't work my personality and so I avoid
it because my purse is what this is why
I always say to people watch what I do
not what I say I went on there and
[ __ ] me Gary B [ __ ] I didn't make
tick-tock [ __ ] I mean Gary B [ __ ] right
and and the next time [ __ ] lollipop
comes out whatever's going on lollipop
you don't make lollipop [ __ ] you make
black game [ __ ] got it yes you see you
take it easy take your mice you hear
that you hear that yard work in the back
yeah I do it's not too loud though I
just hear a little bit Katie let's do
this Katie Katie hi how are you awesome
how are you I'm well were you from Iowa
City Iowa I love it I've been I've been
I've been I've been I did a book signing
dinner for crushing awesome yeah I have
crashed it and crushing it so yes thank
you Katie what's kickable real high
level here so I'm a woodworker in an
artist I've got like a job job the
woodworker artist thing is my side sighs
awesome
three and a half years now and listening
to you about the same amount of time so
of course I'm like on everything tick
tock YouTube all of it I'm putting out
as much as I can I also have a weekly
podcast called the maker mom podcast
where I other nerds lonesomer makers
I've been trying for a while to get live
stuff going and then eventually with
like co-head going on right now
I'm really focused on wanting to be
there for this community that I started
building do you have a Facebook group I
do I have a what's it what's it called
for everybody's watching and once
enjoyed okay what's the icon on the
group in case there's other maker mom
groups so I've been trying to do the
line and I've been doing polls across
the different platforms like which ones
I'm getting more interaction from so
that that's what I'm doing my live
stream from and I get more interaction
on the polls on Instagram but then when
I go live on Instagram I get like
crickets
I get almost nobody there what about on
Facebook because I don't get any
responses on what here's a good thing
you you shouldn't go with the poll as an
indicator you should just [ __ ] do it
and see what happens right I mean look
what happened you got more engagement on
the poll on the Instagram but newbies on
you may go live on Facebook now that may
not work as well so then I would go into
the Facebook group and say ladies how
many people in the group amazing say hey
guys this really matters to me I really
really really want to get the live thing
going I'm gonna go live on Facebook
tonight at 7 p.m.
wouldn't mean the world to me if you
just said what's up and tagged one
friend it would really mean a lot to me
boom now you got your 27 and you got
your base and you're off to the [ __ ]
races both always leverage a prior
platform when you want to do a new thing
on a new platform I'm not sure I'm
watching all these history on people
that are winning on Instagram go into
twit talk it's not popping off and
they're like have you are you sharing
every tick-tock in your Instagram
stories no have you made a main feed
Instagram post of like you know I really
want you to come [ __ ] with me on tick
tock or I'm doing this giveaway on do
this fun thing no I'm like well you have
the one [ __ ] strategy you know so so
always use a prior platform your biggest
platform to build your other plan
then cross pollinate watch what I do not
what I say is something I'd like to say
that's what I do a ton of and that's
what you should do to get your [ __ ]
live off the ground okay awesome
take care yep we are doing it this
morning Dustin it's almost like the
community and I feel like it needs to be
tight we've got one less hour this
morning if you're just joining us only
an hour today I've got some business
stuff going there's a ton of business
they've gone on but late every day I
have to type tea with Gary B Dustin you
know this cuz you probably see it in my
calendar I mean you know I'm X but 11
a.m. I'm done and boom 11:00 there's a
call and I'm on scene and Google hangout
2 7 8 9 10 p.m. just [ __ ] work and
[ __ ] working out here I wish this was
my my job
let's go Thursday well Paulus thank you
so much
there we go dan tor Willer Williger
terwilliger he gets a retweet and a
follow because he followed it perfectly
he shared it and has the Facebook link
so big shot Jonathan what's good hey man
really well awesome so yeah just just
some quick background I grew up in
Philly I live in Burlington Vermont I'm
a product manager at a technology
company and throughout my career I've
always wanted to do more always had
energy didn't know where to put it
I'm a long time father so last spring
started garage saling I've loved it made
a couple thousand bucks I put that in
scope dude five grand started real quick
what was your best flip yeah amazing
spider-man first appearance of carnage
bought it for a dollar flipped it for I
think was like 89 well actually about 10
that came out that what was that from
1989 1990 99 management yep
I bought a load of that was a really
cool character
so I bought a shitload of that [ __ ]
comic and sold it for 12 bucks a piece
and back in the day I was anyway go
ahead but super fired up so I took that
money I started investing in sports
cards they learned that top to bottom
but what I did is I started sharing what
I was learning on LinkedIn and I
publicly challenged myself 30-day
challenge I'm gonna post everyday and
I'll share with people the results of my
profile visits engagement house
by the number of people coming up to me
and we're outside oh yeah like we love
your concert we can't wait to see it I
wanted to broaden that voice so what I
did is I started a podcast called how we
got here UVM stories that features
alumni from my university that unpack
those stories of how they got from point
A to point B I loved that it had ownable
niche and and it's it's about optimism
it's about humility and it's about
practicality I actually interviewed Alex
Litwin your former employee yes yeah
yeah so that that's the most recent
episode if you want to check it out Alex
Alex Alex Alex hit me up the other day
and said doing that podcast gave him
made him realize how much value he got
at Vayner and for me and that really
meant a lot to me good well I'm happy to
hear it he said good things about us he
did yeah he said some great things
there's a short five-minute clip that
I've pulled out and I put up so again
it's how I got here UVM stories and I'm
19 episodes in I've got over 850
downloads I've got some great guests on
would love to you know I'm reaching out
to people like Ryan or so on Jessica
Seinfeld but my question for you is how
do I continue to build on that success
and continue to grow my audience um
first of all you have to realize it's
narrow right yeah so you know it's a
specific success story to a college that
is a small college in the stream of
things not Ohio State you know so um you
know I honestly just listening to you
like the fact that you've taken
information a lot of themes that I
believe in and then executed yeah I'm
super impressed my intuition is you're
well on your way
you have conviction and great energy and
charisma so you're on your way yeah to
your point you're you're eventually
getting to get to the 5 to 7 biggest
alumni which is gonna give you the
biggest reach the question becomes is it
too nice for your broad shoulders you
know my my my intuition is it is brand
so I think it's gonna end up being a fun
side product that you'll do kind of like
kind of like how I want to do I haven't
pulled it off but I've wanted to do Wine
Library to be like once a quarter like
once every hundred days just bring it
back but I haven't pulled it off you you
I think our gonna turn this podcast
probably into something that you do
almost like Barbara Walters back and a
you do it like once in a while it's a
it's I think I could I could see it
happening three to four times a year
just to keep it going but I think you're
gonna take this experience and level up
to something dramatically more broad
that can go forever yeah that's my gut
yeah I'm excited about it I decided to
produce more Nisha's are awesome for
people that are satisfied with and have
the ambition for the upside of
maximizing that niche right nieces are
awesome as springboards to the next
thing while our BTB was the springboard
to my next thing yeah so my intuition is
that's what we're looking at here yeah I
think it's gonna be a springboard cuz as
I've gotten guests on I'm like I'm
getting good at this
and like and people are reaching out to
me outside of UVM bro I can tell you
right now you're good at this I'm
interacting with you right now you're
good at this I think what you need to go
to now is the most broad thing that
you're interested in okay okay
whether or not sign ourselves whether
that's mindset whether that's mentorship
you just need to go to the media so what
I actually have a second podcast that's
coming I'm mentoring to students from
UVM to help them find jobs and
documenting this experience we started
it in January so now what's it what do
you what's what's it gonna be called so
it's gonna be called how we're getting
there
graduating college so yeah that's that's
a forever thing you know just don't let
it be in the pocket of UVM okay all
right man awesome
got you what a [ __ ] fire episode
Dustin right quick valuables [ __ ] but
the one thing that's pissing me off
Dustin is I don't see a lot of tweets
you [ __ ] start tweeting Gary Vee
screen shoot this share it in your
thoughts link to LinkedIn or Facebook
slide but talk to me here like this is
ridiculous I need way more jaws and good
[ __ ] Richard thank you so much Gabriella
Costa you get a [ __ ] follow on your
11th [ __ ] follower on Twitter that's
a [ __ ] win in my opinion let's go hey
Michelle
hey Gary as you're saying this I'm thank
you this I've been doing it I'm like
[ __ ] I haven't done it yet you can ask
your question you get a pass
that's awesome Wow this is [ __ ]
believable man I am such a big fan of
yours you know not even because of the
motivation stuff because I'm a pretty
motivated person but I love that you
just keep it real and you are in my head
so much even and I'll tell you so like
my question that I first admitted was
you know how do I keep my side hustle
sort of separate from my day job when
they're related and because I'm kind of
like trying to protect it and as this
process has been going on watching you
everyday and continuing making content
and doing my thing I it's almost kind of
been answered and I in a way I mean you
know I'd still love to hear about it so
I'm I'm in Miami Florida born and raised
in Puerto Rico and I work I'm an
athletic trainer I work with mainly
recovery and Rehab for athletes but I
work at a high school and that's been
kind of my bread and butter and so I
started you know talking and connecting
both on Instagram and Facebook with kind
of different audiences Facebook is more
my sports moms I really realize that
like they're on there and I just started
III took a step back and instead of
doing a jab and putting something
together and selling it you were in my
head and I'm like that's not worth it I
don't want the quick money I just want
legacy longevity so I've been like
infiltrating groups I have a small
private group of my own and anyway it's
been really cool so I've been kind of
juggling between talking to the parents
on Facebook talking to mainly the young
athletes on Instagram because I feel
like there's a lot of information out
there obviously in this space about
training and exercise in rehab and
recovery but I wanted to kind of put my
spin on it and talk directly to like
these kids like cuz like I refer to them
as my kids like every athlete I worked
with like it's like my [ __ ] favorite
thing when I get to work with someone
and like you know something happens and
boom we get them
back on the court like that's like the
biggest hi so that's like my saying look
you've got you've got your aunts like to
your point like I can i the answer is
you know you can and so just a matter of
time before you switch that's just
having the GU guts to jump in the pool
or kiss the boy right like that's that's
just gonna be a transition period where
you're gonna make a call to your point
and what you've learned from me being in
your head he keep bringing value keep
bringing value you should start a
tick-tock immediately I started one and
I'd spend it's been a process I it's fun
I love it I get it because I'm around
high schoolers all the time so I totally
you know I get the culture I mean how
many posts have you made I have you've
judged your inability to make something
that works too soon yeah I understand
everybody makes this everybody makes
this mistake Gary I'm in there but it's
not working for me how many of you made
six six no yeah no no we're staying on
this sorry yes you're right yes I'll
tell you why I can tell that you have
actual authentic love for these children
I want you to win junior high because in
24 months you winning tik-tok is game
over yours dentist is winning on there
there's [ __ ] people that sell [ __ ]
like bananas winning on there like you
go do you don't try to go dancing and
[ __ ] do you just put out the content
edit it overlay with words play with it
play with some music but like do you in
there I need to add a from you during
this [ __ ] coded not six all-time
before we make them I don't want to hear
from you that you can't do
[ __ ] tick tock until you post 280
times yeah look understand it clicked
where I'm like well [ __ ] let me I'm
fully bilingual and like I'm doing this
so I just threw something out there like
in Spanish and like it won't come over
there like oh I didn't know and I
started sharing my story like this is my
story you know and yeah I signed up
lives with two people that have that
have way bigger audiences and me one
English one Spanish is talking about
whatever training this and that more I
got more more and so I'm keeping it I'm
like take advantage of this time right
now go hard hard hard I'm proud of you
you got it more more platforms more
contact more lives the answer right now
is [ __ ] more what are you gonna sit
and watch the news get depressed [ __ ]
go ham ham ham ham ham more more MORE
yeah thank you sir you too [ __ ]
episode I'm [ __ ] fired up I've got
some nice numbers on Facebook too
let's share Facebook peeps share that
live right now in your feet it would
mean the world to me let's get people on
there it's just nice and the feedback
gets me going Thank You Zack Pereira
following you bro under 7th [ __ ] file
or Zachary let's go let's go yeah
Justin's working on his thing
Michelle Duffy run Ben you get a retweet
mmm
Dakotah farlis Susan how are you I'm
great how are you I'm super well what's
good um so my question for you is we
have a virtual office receptionist
service where we provide a variety of
small business owners and midsize
businesses we've been around for about
eight years it's called dedicated office
come on and we're basically a business
of all women all moms on and so right
now we're seeking a little bit of a hit
because you know our clients into being
a little bit of a hit but we feel like
it's right now is the time for them to
realign and refuel and so we feel like
that we are not obligation basically to
present our service and the answer
basically the way that they're going to
be able to regroup and you know just
grow from this not just survive this to
a group from this because having a
virtual component for us is like the the
answer to all the elements bringing it
all I understand I understand so how do
we convey that in you know a strategy
our next step LinkedIn content is a big
one and and you just convey it you just
you you interview people you interview
owners that have done it with you like
you right now you
reach out to all the clients you have
and be like hey do you want to go do a
zoom with me you record it you post it
on LinkedIn it's content right right
it's cut its content at scale okay it's
not about comparable you know where ever
you know where everybody gets [ __ ] up
they try to convince cuz that makes
sense and I think they need to educate
does that make sense yeah you understand
that you need to you need to be the news
not an infomercial right so put into
your head okay I'm not gonna make an
infomercial on LinkedIn I'm gonna make
pretend that I'm in Bern TV or fox
business or CNBC you understand right
that's do so we're not marketing sell
anything we're looking to kind of
collaborate and educate and that when
you're when you're on a zoom with Rick
Thompson who uses your service and talks
about it and then you post that video on
LinkedIn you're gonna get free organic
reach cuz linkedin's organic reaches are
like your places LinkedIn your content
is interviews and information not sales
pitches got it okay so so that we're a
little confused as to you know which
platform is gonna be best for us it's
time for you to go virtual it's time for
you to eat your own dog food you're
trying to tell everybody to use
technology and you're going old school
and your business development I need you
to [ __ ] go virtual right so we're
starting that so I kind of developed
this persona Susan Serena and I just
started a YouTube channel and I can't
hear you about toxic toxic toxic God for
you picked up is fun and maybe long
long-term but you're right in your b2b
usually right you like this platform
your leg - all right get that eat it and
doesn't matter if you have any followers
you [ __ ] create your account you post
LinkedIn is just like tick tock it's the
only two places on the internet right
now where you can have no audience post
the first time and have [ __ ] go crazy
right right okay all right Dustin I'm on
it today like
kite no tight that's right Geronimo
don't try to convince educate good
little shout out there appreciate that
my man
Trevor Agnew's listening he's got the
logo he's got the URL so he gets a
retweet and a follow I'm his six hundred
sixteen hundred and seven follow her
from Kent England woke up early this
morning so Gary Vee was live I feel like
I've won the lotto Don Juan I'm live
every morning 9:00 a.m. tea with Gary be
it's fire tell me was it
Mitch what is good good morning were you
from North Carolina
fantastic that's good so I went to
school for graphic design big [ __ ]
mistake could've done that show tomorrow
did you collect debt where do your
parents pay me right now but you know
I'm working right now to get that paid
off so okay and they I got a job right
out of college and I'm working for a
payroll company we do like customization
for sports teams like colleges and high
schools across and so I was working
there and I did I did like regular
graphic design [ __ ] for a while and then
they threw me in they saw like I had
potential to do marketing exciting
photography video [ __ ] and I like all
that type stuff so they they had me on
there and they switched me to marketing
and so right now with with this kind of
virus going on like I'm trying to figure
out how we can mark it to the sports
world right now this kind of shutdown
and so I was kind of want to get your
advice on that like we have we'd use
Instagram and stuff like that and we do
who are you targeting like who are you
trying to reach which who's the decision
maker on the sports side so our
company's basically we are worth like
teams and coaches coaches and
James will come to us and get a store
build order they'll happen they'll have
the teether the coaches will just come
and order you know a customized product
for their team and everything like that
like what like it's usually you have
vendors from like Nike under jerseys so
I mean look right now inch there's
nothing gonna be happening you say you
like people are just not putting dollars
to work right now until they get settled
there's too much unknown I think the
reality is right now you have to be
building great look the question is are
you making branded content for you
making sales content and any and that's
what you need to focus on having a good
mix of both and right now I think more
branded content to build awareness of
the company because converting on sales
driven content is just not going to be
there for business like this I think
this is most of the content sales driven
like hey I think you're kind of like
Target what we can do like keep went
home like kind of stuff they can wear
like working out I think where we need
to be a mint or just the brand I think
so I also think LinkedIn is a very very
important platform for a business like
this that has b2b dynamics so keep that
in mind appreciate it
do you like the job yeah I mean it's
interesting keeps me entertained you
know I definitely I don't have a
background in marketing so I'm learning
yes I'm still learning but you know do
me a favor spend $50 on Instagram and
Facebook Ads
so that you learn how you you because I
think you learning that as a creative is
a very powerful combo right they'll be a
good addition to your career all the art
kids need to do a little bit of math
[ __ ] and all the math [ __ ] kids need to
do a little bit of art [ __ ] that will
make them complete in the world oh we're
now living in yeah take care of me stay
down [ __ ] good stuff
can drill in here you want your question
aunty with garyvee it's two one two nine
three one five seven three one two one
two nine three one five seven three one
is how you get it I love what's going on
here a lot of sharing on Twitter now now
we're feeling it now I'm feeling it
fresh sparks thank you so much it is
fast and furious today it is fast and
furious
today what is good Cedric I'm super well
pleased so your time is a lot so I'll go
ahead and get into it I've been doing
YouTube for about six five six years now
I'm at about 50,000 subscribers and
basically what I do is I love music I
love singing and I musician and I love I
love talking about music and so my idea
was I feel like my strongest asset my
personality and so I I wanted to create
something to where people could watch a
video they could relate me to whoever
their fate was and then create that
connection and then we saw the
conversation from there my question is
I've been trying for the past couple of
years to financially get to a point
where I can I guess focus on growing for
a couple of years so I'm trying to get
to a financial point to where I can you
know have an apartment in food whatever
just go assess taken care of and then I
can focus on just creating content and I
also want to be able to have like a it's
all public sounds weird but I want to
have a mentor every day for like the
vocal mentor I want to learn Spanish you
know personal trainer just have
different things every day so I'm
constantly learning and constantly
growing and just however they can my
life where I could just focus on
building my problem is that I'm having
trouble figuring out how to monetize
that because I've tried patreon in the
past and I got a couple of people but it
wasn't really working and maybe it was
my offer I tried doing merch but I sold
some since I had one sponsorship dollars
which wasn't crazy so I'm just trying to
figure out that's my first question I
had one more super small question but
couple things one have you debated the
fact that maybe hiring a manager or
business partner could be a good move
because you could
get into a place where somebody who
might have more business strengths might
be able to bring you value that's one
debate there's also the concept of
finding something you like that makes
money that becomes part of your content
you know so like thrifting with cedric
being a video each week that is exactly
what trash talk is with me where you
literally film yourself going to a
thrift store spending 20 bucks and then
posting all the items on ebay and making
500 bucks or 200 bucks you know I always
I always dreamed about doing a show like
trash talk where I go and film myself
buying something at a garage sale or a
thrift store in the state sale and then
list the items on eBay or wherever and
then when the show airs those auctions
go live so that the audience actually is
the one bidding on the stuff okay so
climate well it doesn't
like we're not leaving our [ __ ] home
right so this is a little bit maybe 90
days from now but and and that's just
one thing that I know would work and
maybe you're like yeah Gary but I don't
want to go through a story you know but
like something that actually makes you
money that becomes your content here's
one again might not fit your personality
but obviously a lot of people are
watching and try to give ideas maybe
maybe there's a segment called side jobs
with Cedric right it's a once a week
show and you literally get random jobs
to pay you 200 bucks 150 bucks 300 bucks
you mow lawn you cut it like I think
there's a creative way to film what
you're doing that makes you money and it
kind of all feeds itself do you see
where I'm going yes I do turn the money
making into the content and then it kind
of self populates I mean I think the
thrifting would set like are you are you
into the idea of like goodwill and
grudge I think that's a monster with
50,000 subscribers I think that's a
monster I think once a week you film
yourself with your iPhone doesn't you
know oh I like this you know I like this
hat this is cool or like this lamps cool
you like film yourself listing it and
then that's the episode your fans been
on it
it just sells on ebay naturally I think
there's something there I've been
thinking a lot about that model and it's
an addition to your content on the
singing stuff I also like the side
hustle concept where like literally
you're just going on Craigslist and make
it 75 bucks here 100 bucks here and it
becomes like a whole funny thing you're
just like you know just imagine us--
you're doing like you're cleaning out an
old lady's basement for 80 bucks but the
whole time you're singing down there and
that's the content yes yes for sure for
sure
that's the architecture oh cool so other
people in my space were big you know as
well if I go through their comments
section and interact with their
followers is that disrespectful it can
be I think one where you bring a lot of
value like you watch the video and you
say something thoughtful instead of like
instead of like let's call it what it is
reply to all their followers with the
hope that they come and watch you look I
think if you leave a great comment like
oh I really like how you know I don't
know music well I love how you hit that
high note on the [ __ ] bridge like
something that brings value and
consistent you will get 10x okay how you
get your followers is more important
than how many followers you get there's
a guy right now who leaves a comment
every time on my instrument posted like
everybody who follows me now I'll follow
back and it just spam Destin shaking his
head so he knows and I was like a kid
that I thought was doing some decent
stuff but now I'm like ah that's just
[ __ ] especially cuz he's not actually
following everybody back don't be full
of [ __ ]
everybody plays it throw away time what
is up John Gary how are you man I'm
quite well you could not be any better
at all first of all man just really
wanted to say thank you for doing this
like it's just so amazing like I'm a
huge believer in the idea that like the
world doesn't happen to you it happens
for you and it's just like I don't know
I'm devastated by everything that's
going on but there's just so many
wonderful things that are happening like
as a result so do you really think
before that man so thank you
question is like how do you know when
the right time is to move on from a
company so to provide you with a little
bit of context on me in my life like I
grew up always wanted to be an
entrepreneur
my dad's an entrepreneur I kind of grew
up always wanting to be like my dad and
basically I don't know I never loved
school I started this like small
landscaping business when I was in grade
11 like print out flyers go knock on
doors got three clients one of them
being my dad but versity and I came
across this opportunity called student
works management program so basically
what is it what it is is it teaches
students how to start and grow their
first business while they're still in
university so it's like painting or
window cleaning so you kind of think of
it like a franchise so it's got all the
systems and everything but you don't
actually have to buy into it as a
student we actually invest into the
students so basically I started with
that company ran my own painting company
for three summers like my first three
summers the university did about two
hundred sixty thousand dollars there and
then I became a business coach and a
district manager with the program so
okay here's what I do now is I basically
coach and mentor and recruit and train a
group of 18 students to go run their own
painting companies and I literally walk
them through from the moment they start
right through to the end of the year and
there's that organization of for-profit
or nonprofit work it's for profit for
profit okay and how do they make their
profit
so we basically only make money if the
actual owner operator makes money so we
take a peek and you take a piece of the
percentage understand fantastic okay and
so you're ready you're ready to move on
potentially but potentially but like I
just love it so much like the amount of
like creation I'm able to go and do like
the impact that I'm able to have on
these students it's like literally
compared to nothing else and I guess
yeah I guess I'm kind of cool about this
spot where basically like I think if I
do the right things over the next couple
of months like finish this euro strong
you know I could potentially carve out a
spot on the company for me to kind of go
up and take on a little bit more
responsibility in terms of like the
social media side branding and like some
of the strategic innovation of the
company or maybe like coach one of the
people that are kind of in my
position now yeah there's a lot of stuff
that's kind of up in the air but really
like for me to see my plant through
fruition for me to like make the company
you know just an indisputable force for
student entrepreneurship in the country
like that's a three five year things so
I'm not really making decision whether
or not I want to stay four years like
you are yeah you are you've created an
ideology on the three to five you're
making a one-year decision you're making
a six-month decision okay you've I mean
why not four to six why not eight to
nine for the rate you you've created
this happens all the time
you've created a theoretical good news
how big is how big of an organization is
it we do 20 million like we've been
doing this since 1981 right so I'm not
so sold that you're gonna make this
iconic impact in three years you you're
what you're doing is you can't come up
with an arbitrary number that still
allows you to be young when you're done
with it to go and do your own thing yeah
and by the way like I also see a
possibility where I stay on even longer
than five years you might become the CEO
one day right yeah so let's so let's
let's let's let's finish off this thread
that I have a strategy on you're making
a six to 12 month decision the end first
of all you're making a day-by-day
decision like every other human but for
the fun of this conversation do not
think you're making a three to five year
decision because then it puts you in a
trap and that's what you're actually
worried about yeah that's definitely
because I don't know I hear we talk
about with like people that are like I
know you are clearly passionate about
people and entrepreneurship and
operations good news you you you know
listen there are some blessed people out
there that just know what they like or
like something like something that is so
universal I like the process and I like
the flip and I like the marketing and I
like the sales I like business and it
could be this hat and it could be my dad
happened to have a liquor store if he
had a tire store I'd be Gary [ __ ]
tires you know what I mean like
so I love the process and I think just
listening to you you might have that
same exact thing going so yeah I think I
think you're in a good spot and I think
you need to just realize you're not
you're not signing a three to five year
ironclad contract you made that up in
your brain and it's [ __ ] you up yeah
no I I definitely did do that cuz I
don't know I guess I just hear you talk
about with like patients right and I
know that to really build that like
we're starting to really build our
social media like that's something we've
really taken on in the recent years and
I were doing great I think we can do
even better and so I guess my three
five-year thing was you know I really
what I want to do is increase the amount
of proactive applications people that
are reaching out to us again it you want
to build a brand exactly yeah it's a
it's a sales organization now and you
want to make it a branding organization
where it comes to you I get it
you see bro you need to just decide for
yourself like every six months every
three months every nine months every 12
months if you like it if you're ready to
do something else
don't create ideology you create an
ideology yeah absolutely
thanks everybody who's watching tea with
Gary B today I'm sure I'm sorry it's an
hour shorter but some operation stuff
Dustin thank you for the ones and twos
thank you everybody on social media if
you have a question for tomorrow - one
two nine three one five seven three one
if you're in America and Canada you can
ask a question there is a dark-horse
chance that there will be an evening
show tonight called wine with Gary vine
or Chuck so team let's start designing
on that it looks like it would be in the
ballpark of 6:00 to 7:00 p.m. Eastern
if you want that hit me up on Twitter
and demand it I will see you all
tomorrow if that doesn't happen 9:00
a.m. Eastern on tea with Gary Vee Friday
edition thank you so much see ya have a
blessed anyone of them see if there's
any people outside of community for
tomorrow or like we did last week we'll
figure it out but right now I'm good
okay
you